hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to calm down Stalin now I
honestly don't have any idea what this
game is about but just judging by the
looks of it it seems to be an absolutely
ridiculous adventure that it's gonna be
completely understandable stamping the
documents correctly can increase the
state integrity okay it's something like
that that leads me to believe that I
have no idea what this game is about you
see how those words in that sentence
they don't mean anything they're very
illogical anything why would stamping a
document has any effect on state
integrity or the people just gonna be
looking at how accurate my stamps are oh
hi place your head near the button to
threaten your enemies oh I won't do it I
don't know what Stalin sounds like but I
think he sounds like this oh you want me
to press it don't you hey boy oh you
press the button the order of war is
inevitable now alrighty then
drinking some vodka reduce substantially
well I'd like to think so but I can't
really drink anymore okay we just can I
pick up oh oh yeah oh you oh you think
oh you think
oh hello ah make it the peyten smoke to
relieve stress well I I don't know where
the five Wed oh it's right here can I
put that down poof poof poof I am very
less stressful what was that you
threatened me oh I don't take kindly to
threatenings don't you know who I am
oh oh oh he's got a rumbly in my tumbly
or was it war phone unlocked ending the
call abruptly are failing the answer
decreases the state integrity I can't
believe it took them so long to get a
phone in my new study time to make some
coal
war is at the door today is the
beginning of the endless threatening for
the sake of the peace okay accurate
gunshots reduce the stress and increase
the state integrity again the
nonsensical nature of these intro screen
seems to be dabbling with my mind oh
what's that huh that's what I thought oh
my heart or maybe it was war I've got a
rumbly in my tumbly
or was it war excuse me hello aha yes
huh this phone is this phone looks weird
it smells weird too
alrighty then where's my pipe her proof
I'll perf I'm Stalin sure is good to be
Stalin
Oh I'll do it I'll do it all right oh
I'm about to do it oh [ __ ] he bout to do
it hello
eat a dick oh yeah good job me
I'm doing great Oh lamp cause stress
while flickering hit it with your hand
to fix it oh okay
it was too dark so I've ordered a new
bright lamp to be brought for my table
they should hope it works good The
Closer your hand is to the button the
higher the effect yum yum yum in my tum
tum tum who's ready for war
oh [ __ ] god dammit to do that good thing
they have a constant livestream oh where
did I put my wallet ah [ __ ] where'd I
put that war Boston oh yes I'm very
close to it now if I don't look at it I
won't see the light if I just smoke my
pipe in the dark maybe I can get the
menacing brooding effect oh look how red
this botanist it's so good thing it's
over this game is rigged goddamn dick
Ulis was getting used to the new lamp it
flickers gather the ministers and the
officers and get ready to stand our
ground
optional do the most stressful and
tiring state business the state
integrity will greatly improve but have
costs too personal tiredness whatever
let's continue on failure to hit the
target with the gun can reduce state
integrity okay I get it somewhere
there's a gun no I didn't do that here
up I'll do it I'll do it I'll do it
oh I'll do it oh I'm so tantalizingly
close to that what ten yeah good thing
I'm not looking in the general direction
where I'm working oh wait there's my
finger maybe I'll stroke my must
who the [ __ ] hello yeah uh-huh
okay yeah okay goodbye war bit about me
to be driving a baby die war oh you
wanna press it so badly
oh geez yes look where you're going my
god who knew that being a head of state
was so damn important it looks more
menacing when the light is flickering
but that's also seems to be increasing
man no I was going up I was almost done
with that one goddamn it
oh you sons of [ __ ] all around the
world need to back the Frick off because
Stalin means business pawpaw everybody
back off everybody calm down do your
hands off the nuke buttons even though
mine is on it I'm not gonna answer that
phone because I got war being declared
ah finally okay we made it progress
vodka drink to significantly reduce
stress ring the bell to order so I'm
just gonna be a non-stop drunkard the
entire time I'm in the head of state
which is probably pretty historically
accurate there why do I have to leave my
desk to get a drink
there's now an officer responsible for
bringing drinks to me yeah yeah we get
to be drunk I like the sounds of this
all right
then someone put it oh thank you
oh yes all right goodbye puff okay all
right now they're threatening I'm drunk
in my fingers on a button that launches
a lot of nukes
does anybody want to mess with me I
didn't think so
I can't laugh with my eyes closed I got
to keep an eye on this goddamn button
yeah ding dong ding dong please ding
ding ding please oh that was way too
freakin close right in there the enemy
is strong and confident but we have
tools to undermine that confidence let
us use those tools you mean by - you
mean the big red glowing button that
says kill everybody that's right you
better back off everybody better back
off if I'm calm crazy.i who knows what
I'll do Oh
everybody better watch out for Stalin
stink-eye here Stalin's got a good idea
what to do in these certain situations
number one get drunk number two don't
answer the phone number three smoke my
tobacco and then four beat up everybody
in existence bargain evocative are gonna
bar get aboard aboard aboard this
doesn't seem to be going as well as I
could help time for vodka okay oh boy
we're fighting up a storm and we're
almost done but I'm fighting it find it
nerd oh shut the [ __ ] up I need all my
concentrations on this right now old God
you want to push it so badly you want to
push it
ah [ __ ] god damn it was right there
ah [ __ ] you there's no way doing that as
a way to win that it's called not being
a giant piece of [ __ ] but I can't do
that
[Music]